Okay so
let's see what's going on
let's see if I got this figured out
guys are we live
if we're live I just need to know if we
are live
and I could uh I could I could use your
help here because I don't know if we're
live right now are we live Loris in the
kitchen live it says we're live oh my
goodness
I I did not we've had massive internet
problems all day oh let me bring the
chat into here so you guys can see
everything that's going on
Sean if you see the mouse okay there it
is I found it all right ready ah no no
no no no guys I'm gonna fix this problem
really quick everyone be quiet Sean
shush everyone shush I I gotta fix this
no that's the wrong one that's the wrong
one okay everyone I got this
hey Sean do me a favor switch your shout
out some people who are like uh talking
here well Greg fixes the stream right
now we've got 175 people in here so
we've got crashing coyote in oh I lost
it can't shout him out anymore oh Sean
please get it together Sean Chandler
oh here wife gave me the phone we got uh
Gene geeter TV says hello and I say
hello back to you it's Gene Jeter Gene I
don't know how to read I went to public
school in Texas so I barely am literate
embarrassing I'm figuring this out oh
wait no I'm hitting the wrong button
there we go
I'm figuring it out
um so here we are guys so I'm do you
guys know who Sean Chandler is because
if you don't Sean you can leave right
now with your lovely wife yes then you
become Irrelevant in this stream
I'm just figuring I'm just fixing this
for everyone right now boom yeah so I
met Sean he came to the live event that
we did together uh that we did with uh
John campia and Christian harloff and I
just brought you here so that way you
could tell people how good of a job I
did did I do a good job it was uh you
guys actually had great chemistry on
stage and you had said that like it was
a surprise well because you actually had
great chemistry on because you you like
were stealing all the one-liners and
stuff like cutting in whatever they'd
say stuff you'd always sneak in I was
like I didn't I wasn't expecting all the
sneak attacks uh sneak that's that's my
job here and I'm gonna throw you off
your game today
so Sean is uh like arguably the best one
at doing the ranking videos and then I'm
gonna pair up my boy koi genre against
him one day have you ever seen any of
koi's ranking videos
um it's okay if you haven't I'm not sure
if I have but I believe both of us are
going to be maybe at an event in the
near future so there might be something
to that okay well I hope that one day
you guys can do a ranking video together
because Sean does yeah see Beto
remembers in the chat has noticed
that is the the the signature and I
asked Sean this when I met him in person
you do that pose every single time you
don't just you don't recycle it you
could save yourself a lot of time and
energy because your wife is nodding in
the corner but it's more fun to like
work on the flexes to work the biceps
which doesn't work some medicine do you
intentionally work out your biceps in
order to get the photo I see it now
you can kind of see them in the lower
right hand you might see some weights
actually the bar lights on the ground in
my videos are on weights and so
absolutely there are many times where
I'll do this right before doing this oh
that's great to hear guys uh all right
we got to kick this off right now and so
you should do a music reaction Channel
John listen listen
um I'm a little bit off my game
currently I was up really late last
night and normally before doing live
streams I have a method to my madness I
like to Sean this is my preparation okay
I like to uh work out meditate and hit
the sauna I have those three things I
like to do before going live I got a
workout end and realized oh crap Sean's
gonna be at my place really soon I need
to rush back home so I have not showered
apologies and I had noticed something
was
I am I am my whole scent is Biofreeze at
the moment it's just a big a big spray
that smells like an old person and that
is just to uh eliminate some pain we got
314 people here right now but guys
listen I wanted to talk about some
things and I see that we got some super
chats if anyone likes to contribute to
the Super Chat thank you guys so much
for anyone who contributes that means
the world
um but you recovering some movie news
while you've been out here we've got
this California weather going on right
now we could lose internet at any moment
uh it happened many times last night and
Sean has been at an Airbnb I will not
specify exactly where it is but they've
had no power for 12 hours he asked if he
could stay here and I said no not a
chance in hell I don't care for your
presence that much unless we are live
streaming so Sean uh this Aquaman 2 news
I've only seen headlines for it then we
got to get some super chats and then go
to the questions in the chat what is
going on with this all coming Man 2
stuff people are saying it's terrible I
have not read into it but I saw you did
a video on it I wanted to get your take
yeah so I know two people that have seen
it okay screenings you know people
personally who have seen personally
there are people I've personally known
and have known for years that have seen
it at test screenings and
it's it's a little bit tough to comment
on because there have been multiple test
screenings and they've radically
reworked this movie different people in
different screenings are playing Batman
whether it's Affleck Keaton they're
cycling through this place changing and
so the the two guys that I know that saw
it basically said it's fine like it's
it's
nothing that special it's nothing that
special but I mean it's not like the
first one was like Wow greatest comic
book movie of all time they said some of
the adventure aspects were maybe better
okay than the first film it with kind of
the specific team-ups that are kind of
going on there were some other things
they didn't like about the movie but
they said overall like yeah I mean it's
it's up on par with the first Aquaman
now test screenings you got to imagine
they don't have completed VFX very early
you think an Aquaman movie it is like
crazy VFX so it's a little bit like
watching a PlayStation 2 cut scene uh
hours okay and so I remember the first
Aquaman being pretty down to the wire
yeah with uh with the VFX as well and so
you imagine test screenings months ago
the movie still doesn't come out for
another 10 months I mean this was you're
just watching very incomplete Graphics
that's what they said
um but like I said there have been like
six test screenings and they keep
fiddling with the movie they keep
changing their continuity they keep
changing who's going to be involved and
when you do that immediately you create
the scenario where maybe you broke stuff
that wasn't broke in the first place you
without fixing anything because you're
having to fit with all these other
things they're trying to do and
um so that's kind of their take when
they heard these headlines they said
when we saw it it was on par with the
first movie but it sounds like they
they've probably fiddled with it
tinkered with it to death I'm sure the
movie will be fine
it doesn't matter anymore none of it
matters although James Gunn does seem
very very supportive about it it so far
my God he does that announcement he's
like they're all fantastic these are all
great movies like what else is he gonna
say do you think here I just wanna I
wanna I wanna start off like
non-controversial right away do you
think they should recast Ezra Miller
come on Sean we're live no retakes Sean
yeah
um I'm going off with the chat saying
right now I I mean I don't think it's
plausible to read before this movie
comes out in a few months but I think it
would like
so many people will be so offended
you're not gonna text me later about
asking this question are you like how
dare you
um but like
you I can't imagine the scenario where
he continues on after the movie comes
out I mean my wife's actually right over
here and she's like I watched the
trailer I want to be excited about it
but like
Miller is
what it's tough to support a movie with
someone that seems unrepentant of like
multiple potential alleged felonies
that's fair I'm I think um I think I'm
gonna still be able to enjoy it but I
still also expect Ezra to not come back
it's good is one of those situations
where I'm like I think I can enjoy this
I also expect Ezra not to return yeah
that's one of those one of those
situations like I I when they announced
Michael Keaton I mean that was when I
was growing up it was Christopher
Superman Michael Keaton Batman Batman
was the first one of the first movies I
remember seeing in the theater and so
then him coming back yes wow and then
the whole last year overshadowed
something that's so exciting between
Ezra Miller and the DC Universe
imploding rebooting whatever's going on
with it and it kind of like stole some
of that excitement until that trailer
dropped it was like oh yeah oh man I
can't wait to see this I wish that the
star of the movie wasn't
just like tarnishing the whole
experience yeah restart the Snyder verse
am I right
on Netflix I think that's the new one
Netflix save match it save it on there
what's going on in this chat here right
now we do got some super chats I will
get to I promise we will get to that but
I want to see what's going on here
um Shazam 2 is being disposed you know
I'm feeling bad for Shazam too right now
I feel like that is becoming a very much
forgotten film at the moment also guys
if you're here please go ahead leave a
like as we get our brains more sharpened
with the help of g-fuel good call this
is Sean's first G fuel it's true with
Sonic he just had some jack in the box
so you have some high glycemic food it's
gonna spike your blood sugar and it'll
crash which you'll notice Sean with this
G fuel when there's a special promo code
in the description box you will not spy
you're you're you will not crash we will
be alert you will be ready to rock and
get more Jack in the Box after this
excellent well we saved some because
they gave us the wrong order so we have
the second meal once we're done here
there you go leave a like for Jack in
the Box people so Sean okay this people
in the chat have been mentioning several
times now about Shazam too yes theory of
the gods are you excited for this film
because I'm kind of
I was excited but the way how it's being
presented to me is making me go
I don't know if I should invest my
emotion into this right now like when
I'm there I'm gonna like give him my
undivided attention and really and
really give a [__] but but at the moment
I'm like ah yeah like I actually
wouldn't mind waiting until it comes out
on the video on demand to watch it I'm
not I'm not clamoring to go to the
theaters for it yeah
um I don't know it's weird because I
really enjoyed the first one is
something's a little bit different that
uh it was big as a superhero movie
Zachary Levi was great at doing that so
I was totally game for more right and
then when you start to move in the
pieces of like Oh Black Adam played by
The Rock we got a Shazam wow this could
be really cool and it just feels like
with the way everything's played out
it's kind of
steals all the Thunder from that all the
excitement kind of disappears when it
feels like you're building towards
something that's not happening and then
it feels like the reason we didn't get
Shazam and Black Adam is The Rock's ego
that he needed to have his own movie hey
you you leave the rock alone shot you
leave you leave you leave DJ alone
we loved our son for career day was at
the second grade he was he was yesterday
he was just Dwayne Johnson I just want
to be Dwayne Johnson my son says yeah he
had to do a presentation and he did DJ
so we are huge fans of him and I had so
much G fuel I just said something crazy
there that maybe he has an ego and
wanted to fight Superman just excuse the
G fuel talking but it just felt like we
kind of lost out on the best combination
of having a Black Adam and Shazam and
they're never going to meet in this
universe that's why that's crazy that is
pretty wild uh but like I mean I like
the trailers but also March is just so
packed that my amount of excitement that
I can have for each project feels like
spread thin across all of them yeah
that's the benefit of what I do because
I can pick and choose of like I could
wait for it to come out on video in
demand and then just do a movie reaction
to it and then spend like 15 hours
editing that yeah that's just where
that's where I'm at in my life where now
I can go hmm do I watch Creed 3 in the
theaters did you give it a high
recommendation yeah yeah uh it was a
b-plus on it oh that's relatively good
that's that's a solid score it's it's it
there's some clear issues but a bunch of
things I loved okay the scripture that
Jonathan Majors like deciding to just
dominate all of the villain parts and
trilogies uh this month so he was great
and even the story they gave him was
great but there's they cheat a couple
plot points today
hey Daniel parks in the chat thanks for
being here uh can't wait for Cree three
guys I'm gonna put this in the chat
should I watch Creed how do I how do I
do a poll on here guys everyone bear
with me
can I say your wife's name when I
address her do I call her Sean
Chandler's wife uh either yeah Jennifer
or she can't call her Jennifer or Sean I
didn't know if you didn't watch your
name mention she's gotten enough
mentions by now but I called her my
secret wife for years because she'd
never appeared on anything and so I
still sometimes call her my secret wife
[Laughter]
just like a bad inside joke that can
like look horrible off on me but well
Sean's wife Jennifer is in this corner
right now and sitting in one of the most
uncomfortable chairs we have
and and she is just I can tell she's
loving this so much are you loving this
she's loving you you can't hear her but
she said this is the best thing Shawn's
ever done with his career yeah I really
appreciate that Jennifer thank you
um I know John would know how to do a
poll John's not answering his phone
didn't I call John like three times
that's true there's like 10 minutes
um okay but like oh we gotta I I don't
wanna I have a habit of when we get
super chats of waiting way too long to
get to them so I'm gonna check in on the
super chess really quick then we're
gonna go back to the stream but I got
this guys I'm learning to multitask like
a madman I do it every day I do it every
day all right Sean just let me load this
in the meantime Sean what'd you think of
cocaine bear did you love it
um I did not love it it was fun it's
like 30 minutes of the schlocky fun that
you want okay bear cocaine eating people
but there's some long stretches where
you're just hanging out with these
families and these drug dealers and the
like there's a whole subplot about the
the sheriff and his new dog okay and how
he is he is a foofoo dog not like a
manly dog like it spends a bunch of time
on this and you're like really what are
we doing here like and you show up just
all you need is a bear tearing people up
for 90 minutes and then get out of there
and you get the bear doing that but you
get so much just cringe dialogue that it
wasn't quite as good as I was hoping
it's a part of life man all right here's
we're gonna do since we have the super
chats open now we can sit a little
closer together okay excellent yeah oh
there we go now it's not so awkward yes
yeah that's who pushed me away right
here this level of intimacy that we're
gonna it's funny when we took that that
photo who's Andy is his name is your
friend Andy took this photo of Sean and
I when we were having like when Sean and
I got to talking to each other it wasn't
like a
like hey YouTube chat
subscribers videos working comments you
know like did it turn into it you didn't
normally talk with another YouTuber
about it became a very serious
conversation very heavy very quickly
straight we've been here for 15 minutes
oh yeah this is the comedy event that
we're at right we're in a comedy club
talking about like our deep track
I just like instantly subverted to that
and Andy takes a picture I don't even
get there it's so quick it was so funny
anyway Cody Leach Cody leeches your
buddy I I watch Cody's videos
um I have not personally met Cody
um but this is cool to see Cody in the
chat he says cool to see you two hanging
out having fun I think Cody's probably
very jealous right now I'd imagine so
yeah all right all right please I need
my ego he's fanned I'm sure he's very
jealous thank you the people I'm getting
to hang out with but he's not jealous of
having to drive around in La during
whatever this rain it was hailing while
we were driving over here hitting our
car like what is going on in LA this
weekend but yeah I went over to his
house for a week a year ago and then he
came over to my house for a film
festival last year you guys are like
real buds but yeah we actually like as
soon as covet ended we started spending
a lot of time together and then next
month we're going to be at Mega con
together wow I want to meet Cody in
person he seems like an alright guy so
I'll try and maybe we can do a big meet
up get us all out here
yeah don't do
that please oh [__]
that would be great that'd be great
Roddy Rod in the chat thank you for the
Super Chat thank you Cody for the Super
Chat isn't it harder to AdSense
contributing to our Super Chat I
appreciate you hey buddy Roddy Roddy
said oh snap it's the crossover we've
been waiting for apparently this is the
crossover this is what I've been waiting
for right here I've been seeing that a
lot
when people recognize you do they do
that do they do they come up to you and
and do that
um I think you are the most dramatic of
the people that was excited to do this
how do you not do that but see you think
in terms of thumbnails though in a way
that like you don't have in your actual
videos
the videos I don't like walking around I
think when I'm walking around in real
life I'm not doing this all the time but
if you think of the terms of Thunder I
have real wife and my secret life on
each side of me right here
sorry Jennifer she did not seem to like
that joke I know when a wife is mad now
I've experienced that for two months
straight she she gives me she'll make
faces and she'll make comments I
wouldn't be able to hear them because I
have headset on but yeah that's the
benefit of the headset I usually have
headphones on just to avoid that in my
day-to-day life and then she gets back
to me about that she is looking at me
now I'm getting the eye yeah
are you my wife
Jennifer please do you want to come on
the Stream you sure we have a third
headset
let's streak out a third hand we got a
third headset so she'll do live streams
with me but she'll literally be off
camera so she's fine talking she just
doesn't want to be on camera we get a
hundred dollar Super Chat Jennifer has
to say hi on camera Cody
Trey Porter thank you for the super chat
buddy he says the collab I never thought
would happen anytime soon neither did I
yeah he wasn't supposed to be in town
right this is like this crazy set of
circumstances that
um like on a whim oh my buddy uh Griffin
from film speak text me like you should
go to this Camp yeah Griffin Griffin
Griffin Chiller film speak on YouTube he
does like the oh yes the Striking
thumbnails with the one word like strong
thesis video yes yes so he was at the
show oh I didn't mean him
um he was he was right there
um I met him I I my brain was mush and I
probably failed to do appropriately but
so he he texted me to say like you got
to go to this show you you'll get to
meet everybody and it didn't make any
sense because I was in Portland that
weekend and so I just flew in to see the
show and then somehow that led like yeah
I'm a great guy and now we're here like
this wasn't supposed to happen
I'm pretty amazing salute to you Trey
Porter thank you so much for the Super
Chat my friend and uh Calvin Patel oh
this isn't okay here we go we got a
topic we got a topic we gotta we got a
topic Calvin Patel thank you for the
Super Chat going to be a huge second
weekend drop off for Ant-Man 3 is this
concerning for Marvel
Sean I'm curious to hear your thoughts
I'm not really a box office analyst kind
of individual okay are you concerned
guys if you haven't subscribed to Sean
Chandler's Channel please go ahead and
do so he puts a lot of work into those
videos and those ranking vids are
fantastic I appreciate that why is your
jaw dropped Jennifer
oh Thunderclap oh yeah yeah God's
raining down on us today yes
box office is that them talking about as
the Thunder raining down on the Marvel
box office right now the tweet that I
saw said it had an 80 drop Friday to
Friday now those are always inflated
numbers because Friday includes the oh
first Friday includes Thursday nights
that's tacked on to Friday got it so
there's always going to be a
disproportionate drop there but it also
means a 70 drop for the weekend is what
is estimated which is that's that is a
large drop uh even in terms of Marvel it
usually is pretty front loaded and
Ant-Man three it was a great opening for
the Ant-Man movies but if you compare it
to the Batman Thor love and thunder
wakanda forever or Doctor Strange 2 it
was substantially lower than all of
those movies so softer opening when
they're like we're bringing in Kang
we're kicking off of this phase and then
70 drop that's not good there's no and
then you combine that with tied for the
lowest round Tomatoes score
there's no positive at the end of the
day it is even though the audience score
is bigger it is the lowest Cinema score
yeah yeah tied with eternal Zone Cinema
score as well and I think there's just a
lot more people that are being like
this this bag of tricks isn't working
like it used to and you're you're trying
to force things that aren't working like
they did do you think the weather has
something to do with it
um I mean I mean it could be like this
like I can't factor in a little bit but
like if you're here in La like so we've
gotten four amber alerts in the past 24
hours of don't leave your house whatever
you do so like I'm in town to go to the
Hollywood critics association words that
and we're getting like getting ready and
our power was out yeah and we're getting
these texts saying don't leave exactly
yeah that's what I mean are we gonna die
we kind of go to the award ceremony
that's my concern so we did risk it but
I I don't think there's any positive
spin on it I think Marvel should be
worried about what's going on yeah they
hear that feige Sean Chandler talks
about your failures Rotten Tomato scores
dropping Cinema scores dropping box
office is dropping
you have they have to take notice at
some point guys leave a like if you're
concerned for Marvel
last night I showed her the she hasn't
seen it yet I showed her the character
poster they put out for Modoc and it was
for like 10 minutes she's like seriously
what is this like who is this I'm like
this is a new poster she's like why does
it look like that I mean that's
obviously not from the movie it's like
what's going on here
all right here we are Matt
uh thank you for the Super Chat Matt he
says Sean have any of your Insider
friends seen the flash what do they
think of it I've heard nothing but
amazing things from the test readings I
haven't heard a single bad thing from it
so quick answer no they have it
slash the people that go to test
screenings know the people at test
screens because obviously the people
yeah so my guys haven't recycle like the
same people
um because it's that you like you sign
up for it yeah and so then I mean this
one of these guys I mean he's seen
Batgirl he's already seen the new
Transformers movie
times yeah can you imagine being that
like I have seen
have you seen the Batgirl Brandon
Frazier in the movie yeah he's like I
haven't seen it because I just wanted to
see it complete I don't want to see the
incomplete version so the villain of it
Brandon Frazier has not seen the movie
but my guy has seen the movie he hasn't
seen the flash but he knows all these
people that have and he said everyone
says it's a blast yeah every that's
everything that I've heard
um and I I'll probably have more
thoughts on this in the near future one
of my guys knows someone that worked on
it he's going to kind of give me some
information on some of that but he has
not yet well I've heard nothing but good
things at the end of the day I'm gonna
bet I mean I'm gonna be in the theaters
right like I'm gonna
enjoy it I'm just going to do I'm going
to I'm going to actively choose to yes
enjoy even if I hate the movie
I'm gonna say I like it that's the kind
of reviewer you're gonna get
no honesty anymore okay I'm canning that
on this channel Corey antonacci thank
you so much for the Super Chat The Perks
of Being Wallflower is such an important
movie to me and I've been avoiding
rewatch because I'm worried it will be
tarnished due to Ezra
it is a thing where I'm very much aware
I'm watching Ezra Miller now right even
even when because even when I watched
The Flash trailer I have this like weird
Association when I'm watching it where
I'm like I can I actually feel like
Ezra's doing a good job
but I'm still really aware I'm watching
Ezra Miller now that Ezra Miller yeah
two Miller I am aware I'm watching Ezra
that's the strange part about it where
it kind of happens like that with almost
anyone who falls from Grace right now
um even with Mel Gibson now I get that
way with this straight to DVD movies
I buy them all video in demand 25 bucks
right um yeah that is this strange
feeling I know I get when I watch Ezra
Miller where I'm like
I'm still aware now even if I can be
like yeah they're doing a good job
I've not complete I have I guess I still
have a hard time getting even when I
like re-watch Zack's cider's Justice
League I I have this challenge of
getting but some sometimes I have that
even with like the last of us at times
because I know the game so well where
sometimes I can have a hard time getting
completely lost in it because I'm
compared sometimes my mind starts
comparing to the game it's not the same
thing of course so I'm sorry that's
happening to you Corey I've never seen
The Perks of Being a Wallflower have you
I haven't either yeah unfortunately
because we're men and we Flex in our
thumbnails We're not gonna watch the
perks if you know officers
that's why that's why we haven't seen it
I know we got more Super chats but we'll
we'll put this away for we'll go we'll
check back in with the super chats in
just a minute I want to see what's going
on in the actual in the other chat right
now
oh let me fix this Sean I'm gonna fix
this look at this whoa
Jen how are we holding up
are we doing good Jen you sure
we're positive are you Tweeting about us
are you in the chat you're watching on
the phone okay if you looked at this
interface what he's using OBS I'm gonna
push you here Sean oh that's right you
gotta move over again honey can you take
notes of this OBS system that he's got
going on and then implement this into my
work when we get back home yeah you've
got John I've got Jennifer uh yeah
actually no my my wife has actually
helped me out a lot when it comes to
like video topics and stuff too and I'm
like oh yeah I need to find something to
do because I I'm like I need I need
something I need something I'm just
gonna go to some random things I'm
trying to refresh this chat a little bit
look at this this guy Cool Bros in the
chest and oh my God it's Sean I love you
it's been a lot of love for you in this
chat oh
thank you
you know I I wanted that to happen but
now that it's happened I've noticed it's
taken some of the attention off me and
I'm not sure how I feel about that uh I
I can try to be less pleasant pleasant I
think it would help me out yeah let Cody
cook
um Cody's a great cook that's like it
would it's not immediately obviously
talk horror movies because I say at his
house and like his whole family Dynamic
revolves kind of around food in his
cooking because he cooks everything and
it's all phenomenal yeah and it's all
it's different styles like whatever
you're interested in he knows how to
cook it like the fancy way which you
would not at all like I was not like I
knew he liked to cook I was like I
wonder what that means oh like he's a
legitimate cook
foreign
[Music]
what do you think about the river
there's been a lot of comments in the
chat about
um
about uh flash what do you think about
that rumor that's going around of Ezra
of Grant Gustin taking over I I don't
believe that at all I don't I give no
validity to that because you just stop
and think about it that's a CW hit show
yeah CW hit show means you're canceled
instantly on any number any other
network
um CW I don't know how any of those
shows have kept going I don't know how
you can keep a clean slate too right
it's like this person who's had a
10-year history in a TV show throw him
in the mix like what yeah and like even
with the TV show I watched the first
like seven seasons or whatever I stuck
out pretty long and then I threw in the
towel like this which is the same thing
over and over again I did throw in the
tap the towel on it yeah anything how
many people are in that category that
threw in the towel why would you take
that person to carry on your 300 million
200 million dollar franchise movies yeah
I think I wouldn't do that five seasons
in is there someone who you have in mind
to be the next Superman I'm thinking
Finn wolfhard
how do you guys feel about that Jen what
do you think about my Finn wolfhard pick
you don't know if in wolfhard have you
seen stranger things
have you seen him age in stranger things
no you don't like that pic
that's all I got
it so my what I always go with with the
casting of these iconic characters
it's just kind of fun introducing my
sense of humor sir
[Laughter]
um I always want an unknown or an
up-and-comer someone that's not obvious
like uh whenever they do the James Bond
castings they're like they should get
Tom Hardy they should get Tom Holland
they should get Tom Hiddleston some
other Tom H they like keep picking these
same people that are already associated
with Loki Venom like I don't want that
same with Superman one of the things
that's so great about Christopher Reeves
is that that was it one of the things
that worked so well for Henry Cavill
he'd been acting for 10 years but he
didn't have a thing yet you just see him
you don't see all the other roles Ben
Affleck I I like him as Batman but he
carried in being Ben Affleck into being
Batman that's fair so what do you think
about Matt Damon and Superman huh I
think we can all agree as long as they
keep Ben Affleck that's an incredible
pick and a failure of the universe if
that doesn't happen I loved Ben Affleck
there hey do you what other YouTubers do
you know Sean that's coming up on the
chat quite a bit
um what but someone just asked about Dan
Merle I met him last night for the first
time he's a great guy isn't he yeah
he's one of the higher ups at this award
show so he was like having a busy night
as he could tell he was a little bit um
like
um fried from that but like yeah
friendly and it was great to finally
meetings very tall guy very very tall
um that's my Takeaway on Dan's
personality yes
he's a tall gentleman but Austin Burke
I'm doing an event with awesome and John
Flickinger next month
um he's great too he's really good oh
you got to get him to do this okay I
gotta get those muscles on camera so I
uh um I called him just to like schedule
the details on this we end up talking
for two hours literally I call him oh
really I don't want to waste his time
like all right we got to work out the
details on this two hours we end up
talking about life and YouTube and
movies and the insanity and everything
so that was fun like I've been watching
him 10 years yeah I get his phone number
call him and he wants to talk for me to
two I was like wow life is wild that's
so funny I met I met him the first time
in I went to the Zurich film festival
and I met John flickpick uh there and uh
we hung out a lot Zurich yeah wow and um
yeah it was great I remember we were
working out at the gym and you know
obviously all the women just kept coming
up to me the entire time and completely
ignoring him he was shirtless and people
were like Ugh
Jen are you familiar with this guy
yeah super gross
physically unappealing
[Laughter]
when all the ladies were just clamoring
for Greg
anyway that's the narrative we're going
to go with he's not watching this back
uh we have talked about the early test
screenings and uh yeah Spider-Man being
the lead in the King Dynasty
I don't know that is one thing I'm very
curious about actually I think it was
your friend at uh basically this
question doomsolutely has in the chat I
know we got more super jets that came in
I don't I don't want to fall super
behind on them I I hate when I do that
uh because they're really delayed the
show but
um real quick Jen are you bored
okay you sure excellent okay
people pleasing
the heart is this especially on YouTube
when you just met her five minutes and
I'm like I'm like I really gotta make
sure she's comfortable right now this is
some angry annoying
um okay so yeah we got the Lord of the
Rings talk what was I just about to
bring up do you know could you read my
mind did you know what I was about to do
something oh yes he has Andy brought up
the question to me like who he he was
like who do you think the new lead of
the Avengers is gonna be and I was like
oh that's something I haven't even
thought about which I mean the live show
John Candy goes like who are who even
are the Avengers yeah and the only
reference to the Avengers in the last
five movies was was new member yeah
um and which spoilers Jen have you ever
seen it but Modoc is the new Avengers
he's joined the team
um but so like we don't even know who's
in there and that's one of the questions
I've been asking like who's the new lead
like we kind of had two before with
Robert Downey Jr is like the personality
the fun and then you cut a strategic and
Captain America and they have a great
like dynamic between them and it does
you have Thor there too and it just
doesn't feel like we have
and any anything that's obvious like you
think Spider-Man he can be the biggest
character but you're going to get the
the 20 year old kid to lead the the Army
like I feel like there's a scenario
where he could be I read Kang Dynasty
and I don't feel like it's going to
exactly pull from the King Dynasty run
um
I think it's a fine comic I'm actually
not the biggest fan of the King Dynasty
comic but in that uh I feel like people
who take more of a front and center
approach of the Avengers there are
actually surprisingly wasp who's a great
lead in in quantumania right you know
Great Character Arc really involved in
the story had a lot to do yeah so I got
to know her a lot better I was like wow
she's amazing and this I feel so much
connection definitely a title character
that fits but they have wasp
um uh Carol Danvers uh Thor and Captain
America I would say were a little bit
more of like the
they I think they took a little bit more
front there's like some other more
obscure characters in there who have not
been introduced here who I don't think
are going to be introduced uh but I I
could see them trying to propel some of
them up because I think you know when we
when we had the first set of Avengers it
was like Iron Man Captain America but we
didn't really know I think we just
assumed who the lead would be because
Iron Man was the introduction right
um but even in a lot of runs it's
generally like Captain America is kind
of leaded so uh I I have no idea who the
leader I don't think it'll be Sam but it
would be cool if they found a way to
finagle him in there right yeah that's
my thought process there
um yeah so thank hey thanks Wesley for
just joining us I want to make sure I
don't fall behind here really quick Sean
how are you holding up man I'm good I'm
good there's a lot of questions coming
in I have a very bad habit of giving
long answers to everything so I'll try
to try being here when there's Coy and
John on this trip and then whenever I'm
like we gotta move this along guys one
of them gets defensive with me guess
which one guys
take a guess you know he doesn't know
the channel well enough to get the
inside joke here but you guys you guys
you guys know who I'm talking about
um oh thank you so much Aiden Rivera for
that comment I'm going to check in on
the super chats really good thank you
guys who have contributed to the super
chats by the way scooting together
really means a lot it really means a lot
had a funny situation with I mentioned
this to Sean I won't go into Super
detail about it had a funny situation
with AdSense recently uh where Google's
calling on to like
a large percentage of our earnings I'm
like that's great you know I got to pay
some like employees like Coy and John
and so it'd be great if you could just
you know give me the AdSense that uh we
earned this past month AdSense
yeah yeah YouTube can be a fun business
everyone fun everyone should do it yes
everyone it's good for the mental health
yes very stable no crazies in the
comment section I had someone email me I
had an email this morning I read one
sentence it was a very very long email
and it immediately I was like oh it's a
hate email
and I just deleted it right away because
I was like you know what would be funny
if this person spent this much time to
email me wrote a very long very long
email and I was just like I don't want
to read it yes it takes time I hope
you're watching so that way you can know
like I just around one side I was like
oh I don't I don't want to but I don't
want to waste my time with this yeah I
normally need my wife to help me with
this like what should I say she says you
should delete that yeah respond don't
give them any time block them I used to
let it really get in my head and I'm
like what are you doing with your life
like you got no you got nothing else
better to do you're just gonna send me
you're gonna like literally send me an
email like come on I always think if I
talk to him enough they'll understand
what are you doing I'm so annoying oh
you're rarely gonna convince I I have
had that with comments before where I'm
like oh this this took a turn I didn't
expect this person
it's rare super rare when you always
default to thinking oh they're like me
I'm reasonable no no they think I'm any
crazy people you know that's that's what
this is the crazies
um here we are Johnny thank you for the
Super Chat my friend he says uh favorite
movie theater to go to I do love uh I
got a shout out Cinemark because they've
been amazing to me
however my go-to experience I would say
is a proper iMac screen I don't know
what the it's like Sean's from Austin
yeah I don't know what the imax's are
like in Austin but we have have you been
to the universal IMAX out here no I
haven't been to anyone oh my gosh how
long are you guys out here for only till
tomorrow
well no one's watching Ant-Man this
weekend so if you guys have time I think
you guys should go watch just like that
is that's the theater where Christopher
Nolan screens yeah that's where when he
goes to test his movies it's that it's
the unit it's literally five minutes
away from here yeah and um and yeah that
theater is is like when you first walk
in it is if you're not used to that
screen it's it tends to be jarring
because it's so massive it's imposing
right um but the projection it takes up
the entire thing if they shoot it with
IMAX cameras like I actually hear
quantumania is quite a beautiful to
watch on that screen so that's my
favorite so the in Austin we have one
real IMAX here they have the limex where
they put it's IMAX ratio but in a normal
theater like yeah yeah oh so you do have
a real live we have a real one at the
Bob Bullock museum across the street
from the University of Texas where they
used to you know I mean the way you
described it just like just an insanely
large screen and that's where I saw
um Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol oh
no
in real IMAX is the best sequence I've
ever seen it's just incredible
terrifying Jenna proves that the
terrifying nature what do we think of
Tom Cruise
yes that's right Tom Cruise all the way
you'd be insane calm Cruise you win us
over with you trying to
you risk here I love how his career took
that back do you remember when that guy
was just like a serious actor and now
he's like I gotta win back fans I'm just
gonna risk my life on camera
it totally worked and we're like yeah
man
it's it's
insane Howard how that will work
I love it because he's always he's
always been the guy to do his own stuff
but he took it to another level when he
came back but he came back to winning
fans back you go back look it's the
original Mission Impossible yeah he's on
the train that's not real that's very
obviously there's no stunts involved
they're stuck that is green screen if he
did that now how how epic would it be
for a mission impossible like we gotta
redo the train sequence but do it for
real yeah it's an actual helicopter
Tom Cruise that's how you keep us on
your your path man and we will ignore
anything you've done that you've been
outed for in the past the laser thanks
for the Super Chat could all please just
say hi Mikey I'm your number one fans hi
Mikey thank you so much Mikey for being
here Mikey
is Mrs Sean Chandler you it is oh hell
yeah you got a message
[Music]
wake up my wife
tell her to be a Miss Craig
kick that door open she just spent 12
hours working with autistic children
yesterday and you know what she needs to
get up it's a great introduction
hi I'm Sean's wife create an account now
righteous Rob
hi righteous Rob make sure you boys
check out Destiny good debater what the
game
destiny that I mean that was my guess
but what does the good debater mean I'm
not sure oh oh it's a YouTube channel
desk okay yes one of these days yes
you've recommended them before I will
check them out one day
one day I think I have actually I'm
pretty confident I have a lot of these
like debate channels or essay channels
there's a lot I watch and I forget the
names yeah and sometimes it really
upsets me when I'm like oh I really want
to hear their opinion but I can't
remember what who they're from
um the Werebear thank you the Werebear
hey is this your friend
um that is not Andy no he's saying it
was it was it was great to meet you
Gregory so I was I just thought it was
like a friend of yours yes it it could
be
um because no one else in the chat has
been here yes
um I don't know my brain is a little bit
fried there's been so much can you call
your friends and everyone yes at least
all contacts it was awesome to meet you
Greg at Flappers it was awesome to meet
you too wear bear I hope you introduce
yourself as that I'm the person that
told you I found your channel since your
age of Extinction trailer reaction yes
oh no there you go see now you know who
we're talking about
no is it Jose I think it's Jose I try to
remember I like I met so many people
that night and I try to remember
everyone's name I'm surprised I've ever
had
yes I I think I remember I was it was
like I was checking out the theater
before I went up there yes and you had
your friend with you who had the Batman
shirt I remember you
um you give me motivation to continue
filmmaking
that's what we do here we're making
films so I'm glad yeah he says hi Sean
hello
the werebearer for you
serious that no one no one has asked you
to do that with a photo have they
well I but have they asked me to do it
Sean just volunteers yes they're like
what the hell are you doing
well if there's one person they get this
and then if there's two people like all
right put me in the middle
I gotta do this I demand it otherwise I
walk
it was so funny there's a lot of people
who asked for photos that night and I
thought I always I'll always say yes I
never see them posted that's the funny
partnership
but I'll do these fan Expos on it's 20
30 pictures and then one tag they're the
last person I spoke to that night and so
many photos that night the last person I
spoke to came up to me
and introduced to myself and I was like
I was like oh do you want a photo and he
went
nah I'm okay
I was like
I respect that so that I respect that
thank you for being awesome
and then but then he had me do a video
for a friend of his and I was like
that's interesting okay got a free Cameo
Cody Leach back in the chat this is what
you're talking about 25 minutes ago this
is what I mean how I fall behind on
super chats me too Cody leech if
Jennifer wants me to cook this September
she'll make a quick Cameo Jennifer
Jennifer you know be great if you just
did a cartwheel
you see the frame it's too maybe even
better maybe just knock over the whole
background
Mrs Sean Chandler people would remember
that stream that would be great Sean
Shannon came out and his wife just
toppled over and everything
um
Mars ate guys if you're still here and
you haven't left a like what are you
doing leave a like it helps with the
playback
Sean I hope you share this on your
community page I did that's what I was
doing at the beginning that's why I was
on I wasn't just texting my friends and
controlling Twitter I was uh spreading
the word Marseille production says
thoughts on Steven young casting
um yeah the main rumor going around
is that he's going to be playing a
character called century that's all I've
heard
what would have been smart of Greg today
is if he bothered her research or try to
oh
he's never super shy wow actually he
might have it but oh my god did we see
in the chat uh thoughts on Steven young
casting uh the main rumor going around
is going to be playing a character named
Century I've
definitely read up on Century ages ago I
have barely a recollection on it I
should have researched before I was
specifically told by you that I did not
need to do any prep oh dude that's
that's what a live stream's for
uh no idea what we're talking about the
um as you can see like there's gonna be
topics so with Century he had I remember
having a very interesting I'm talking
about like a general answer he's got an
interesting origin story let's move on
uh uh he I remember his main arch
nemesis being a character called the
void and that's so tied to who the
character Sentry is because it's someone
who like you guys can correct me in the
chat I'm going off of a memory of years
ago here of of this villain who was like
in a way connected to his Consciousness
so Century had to do this thing where he
had to essentially rid himself of his
own memories in order to put the void
down so that way the void could not be
an existence anymore because it's so
connected to who he is so he forgot who
he was and he's literally his centuries
Powers come from the Sun and
basically when new event I think it was
the new Avengers who awoke him and and
and then they found a way to like defeat
the character called the void so if
centuries in here I would if if he is
going to be playing it's all everyone's
under the perception he's playing the
character century and a lot of times
when everyone's presuming that tends to
be right so if he's playing the
character century
considering who that character is I
would imagine that okay so for the
Thunderbolts would that because that's
the rumor that Stephen that's gonna be
Thunderbolts right
I would I would assume then that the
villain might be the void because my
because the century is so tied to that
once they want to do their own
Standalone one but I feel like instead
of doing New Avengers would be
Thunderbolts who awaken Century that's
just my my guess that's all I really
remember about Century I don't remember
like very basic [__] about him I don't
know anything about Sentry so a lot of
ways he's like a Superman powers are all
from like his powers are directly
dropped from the sun he could fly and
[__] but yeah so the other Thunderbolts
rumor was that the after eternals
uh Celestial starts coming out of the
ground yeah and the adamantium is on
there and so they're hunting for
adamantium or something how would that
tie together if that's the case I think
that would be an amazing way to tie it
together I've heard all kinds of crazy
rumors with the Thunderbolts
I am trying to
find a like I wait closer to the
releases because I I do think in the
words of the great John campia don't
turn your speculation into expectation
and uh and I do find I don't really do
that by the time I'm watching the movie
it doesn't the only thing that happened
with like Ant-Man quantumania was not a
speculation turning into expectation
when the trailer is going yeah you want
more time at man I could give you that
yeah that is like you tricked me into
thinking that when I'm like you gave me
a plot that is less interesting than
that is so that's not on me but every
other crazy rumor I had about
quantumania I threw that all out the
window before watching because I heard a
lot of people who were like I think
there's gonna be multiple Kings in this
movie there's gonna be I'm like I don't
guys no please that'd be cool I don't
think it's gonna happen
um but yeah I don't know Thunderbolts
I'm a little concerned for Marvel I am
I'm I am a I'm a tiny bit concern
because I feel like their movies have
not been there's stuff has not been
having as long of a long gestating
impact as they used to I feel like the
the both the top and the bottom have
been lowered yes yes and there's
significantly more things significantly
lower and and there are there is there
is a lot right so like where will finite
I loved I was in love with werewolf by
night and then like something else came
out after I don't even remember what
that next one was but then something
else came out relatively soon now coming
around the time of She-Hulk is that what
happened yeah it was I mean She-Hulk was
it airing simultaneously yeah that's
what I mean I'm like there's so much
Gets In the Mix that that I don't even
have time to just really reflect and
every other big franchise has something
going on television too so it's just so
much of everything going on yeah yeah
and I think you know
um What's the phrase Jen maybe you can
help me out with this distance makes the
heart grow fonder is that what the
phrase is yeah and I think that's what
we need with Marvel would you agree Jen
I'm including you in the conversation
because I'm not gonna put your headset
on over there
you sure can
point it at you does that work
if you ever want to say something I
could just activate it and I could I
could just boom if you want to just say
something
she says she agrees yeah
that's a good phrase men are the
superior race whoa I didn't ask for that
see this is what happens when you don't
have a headset
I'm mansplained
[Laughter]
hey Sean you said a lot down on that
Stephen young question John give me we
gotta move this along hey Sean Sean you
your story has inspired me on my journey
to find myself for about the past year I
hope you guys realize how much you help
your fans every day hear that Sean kind
of inspirational story yeah I uh I
appreciate that and um even so at the
event where I met you
um even some of the stuff I said to John
Campo is of some of the ways of uh some
of his content had um helped me at Hard
Times
um wow
you didn't say about my content I
believe this was before you started your
Channel
so that's why
let's move on
your inspirational story means nothing
to me
your son does have a great story I
remember a sentence or two
no I remember the whole thing it was
really impactful that was something
that's why we had like a deep
conversation it's like when straight to
all of that stuff like whoa now I need
to open up
heavy I would have loved it if you open
up everything and I was like well good
to meet you man
I'm gonna head out now oh cool gotta go
interesting so how does the channel go
Dan v900 thanks for being back here more
people though bought tickets and saw
cocaine bear yesterday than quantumania
awesome people snorting the cocaine bear
a rated R comedy beating an MCU film on
a Friday and second weekend as a huge
red flag cocaine bear doing wonders yeah
you've covered it do you get any age
limited ads on it
um
this was the first thing I've had with a
yellow okay in forever I think I'm just
gonna watch in the theaters because I
don't want you all that worth putting a
video in that reaction again and be like
that freaking title yeah yeah I mean
legitimately
um because it's pretty family friendly I
don't remember the last time I had one
of those yellows and it was back years
ago whenever they had that adpocalypse
and everything everything was getting
tagged this is the first one and when
you put cocaine in the title like hey
what's this about exactly it's about a
bear I'm not telling kids to do cocaine
it's not a bear
it didn't inspire me to give my docs
cocaine I just want to see what would
happen oh I think that would help Scully
to calm down if I gave her cocaine Jen
do you need
[Laughter]
how much cocaine would we have in the
real reason guys
YouTube if you're listening this is
called satire this is not real we are
not encouraging people it affects the
playback and I think we have gotten this
video yellow dollar bill signs here
super chats are appreciated I am not
going to give my dogs cocaine
anytime soon anytime soon dot dot dot
that's the important part uh yeah I mean
I I think that because usually a a
Marvel movie will retain number one for
so long so there is a good point that
you are actually making there and the
flip side to it there's just a novelty
of such a wacky concept yeah you just
want to see like how crazy does this
movie get and I forgot Lord and Miller
were involved in that me too which makes
me want to see it even more
um doomsday 94. thank you so much who
would you like to see as a director to
make a DC movie in the in the reboot
Brad Bird
hey good call Sean there's one that I
have been thinking about a little bit so
I was thinking like who could direct
this yeah movie like Brad Bird Bradbury
Ruby great director for that
he hasn't done a live-action superhero
film has he
what a lazy bum well he got I guess he
got his heart broken because he didn't
get Force awakens and then he just went
back to The Incredibles I didn't know he
wanted Force away he was close he was
like
in the the running up there oh my God
and James gum would totally let him do
what he wants to do that would be
amazing Ryan Shannon prove she got the
nod yeah she's like you're really into
films and these directors and stuff too
are you as much of us are you a
cinephile as well that I mean she was
there with me when we saw Ghost Protocol
with that iMac so there's which
theatrical experiences are like wow
inducing Brad Bird gave one of those
yeah yeah oh Bradbury great okay I would
like to see ariaster director of
hereditary amid Samar dude
that's what I think was like what what I
love about the James Gunn one is that
like he's
it's not
the difference between Disney Marvel
Warner Brothers DC DC Warner Brothers
actually like trust directors yeah the
guy gonna go crazy and that that's hurt
them at times but
they actually trust people so you can't
give him like Ari Esther like go well
what could he do you could pick any
interesting director and
I feel like there's gonna be directors
we're gonna be clamoring for that else
World stuff I think the elseworld thing
is a great idea to give directors enough
I've been wanting to see us like a
horror scarecrow like
scarecrow but like kind of in the vein
of Carrie of a guy dealing with like
bullying in high school like knowing
Jonathan Crane's background
Riff on that it's by Joker movie
basically right that's like literally
the day after James Gunn's announcement
it comes out James Mangold comic book
right Legend
um that would be amazing best picture
nominee director like that guy went I
went Swamp Thing not like an A-list one
like for Swamp Thing they're getting as
high of a caliber of a directors you can
ask for I think Sam raimi's stepping in
would be great too that was when I was
talking about I do steal that from
someone hold on Jen can you see the chat
did someone say sam Ramey
I saw the name Sam
okay someone did say Sarah yeah I think
Samurai would be great yeah he'd be
perfect
yeah where's heavy spoilers jerk you
know have you spoilers Paul I do I do
amazing friend of mine one of my closest
friends
I love him never even met him in person
but but I talked to him every single day
um life of Nate
thank you life Nate Sean meets Greg it's
like the Avengers assembling
that's the plan that's what we're
working on yeah you're like Hawkeye and
I'm Iron Man
that's fair that's fair
that's about right
so anyways
Movie Channel like you both but I feel
like it's too late to start with the
competition on YouTube no
don't say that wait if if
like
you just have to find the right idea and
that right angle and that thing where
you offer unique value because it always
feels like it's too late because there's
always people there's always competition
and when I started a bunch of the people
that started when I started didn't make
it but it's because they didn't find
that unique thing where they were
especially good at it and Sean found
this yeah I think this better than
anyone no one's doing this yeah
it is such a signature God I gotta mix
it up with my stupid faces just
so amazing brilliant brilliant genius I
remember the day I was standing outside
and I went the clouds parted and my arms
Shone down on me it was like it has come
from above my idea
and now here we are here we are it's
that thumbnail man yeah I think I I want
I think I heard Mr Sunday movies talk
about it of how I think it was his
co-host
um Mason who was saying he Likens it to
people being like
I don't think I want to pick up a Guitar
because there's too many bands out there
you know I I totally believe that you
that
what Sean just said is right you know I
I've I've met do you know are you
familiar with the channel I constantly
when I hear something like that I think
of the channel dead meat James do you
know who Demi James is the horror one
yeah yeah I met him in Mexico for uh an
event uh for the nun and I hadn't heard
of him until meeting him and he started
his channel within a year he was at a
million subscribers because he found
something unique to do that he was
passionate about like he honed in on it
like do I think that if you just started
off with going I'm just going to be
another movie review Channel like uh
yeah that's going to be really hard if
your generic brand yeah anybody of your
favorites if you're just knocking off
one of your favorites that's
extraordinarily unlikely yeah you'll
take off
but if you're starting out and you're
being a cover band everyone when you
start playing Guitar you don't start
writing your own songs you start
learning other people's just get the
Reps exactly but then once you've
figured out the Reps in your routine
it's weird to talk to a camera it's
weird to figure out how to do this stuff
yeah once you figure that out then you
have to come up with that idea that's
what's the fresh new thing that's just
similar enough but different enough that
it's interesting and learning to be
yourself more like I think you've been
watching if you've been a long time
followers Channel you probably have seen
I've changed over the years and I've
definitely You See Me Grow you kind of
watch me grow up you know
um it is a fascinating experience but
yeah no I think you just gotta find a
way to just be yourself as much as
possible and find what your boundaries
are as well and your comfortability
um give it a shot though give it a shot
I mean 3C films is another great example
like we're gonna see like a memory has
slow growth and then suddenly he's like
he's booming and now he's like this is
amazing it's like for two three years
Trucking along and didn't get that
traction and then comes up with the
right idea yeah and then he pivoted from
there because it was a little bit too
Niche it was like very Chucky focused
then he pivoted and then just destroyed
it and found something sustainable heavy
spoilers too uh you know yeah same story
of like years of struggling to kind of
find his thing and then boom exploded
so yeah I think um there's you always
got there's an ebb and flow to
everything and you you constantly have
to find that pivot and how to follow
something or something's not working you
just gotta you do have to rework it and
stuff like you can [__] are you the
ranking videos like you've really found
a great
this is impressive it's really
impressive thank you
um Jeff Carroll thank you Jeff hey guys
love all you do wanting to get into this
industry wondering how to start uh what
advice you have mistakes to avoid reason
and place reasonably priced beginner
equipment Etc thinks in advance all love
um I would say that
when I was really building this I was
mainly doing it off a laptop and a
webcam on my laptop so I think you can
really start with anything it all
depends on what it is that you want to
do I I used to webcam until I was
full-time yeah like legitimately built
it to full time using a webcam if it's
just something but now the iPhone oh my
God it's a 4k camera yeah that looks
incredible there are shots in movies
it's amazing using these right here I
mean this one has three different lenses
and it's right there in your pocket and
so and you could you get microphones
like attachable microphones or lab mics
that are cheap like thirty dollars right
and you could just use that it all
depends on what you want to do and you
just figure it out when you're starting
I I would legitimately say use your
phone use a webcam audio is probably
something that's more likely to be
off-putting if you have bad audio so
just get something that's that's good
enough
um and I started off with I iMovie I use
primarily for many years has met most of
the channel as well as iMovie I was
using so I and and to me I I loved that
because even like for the really
intricate sketches I would challenge
myself to go if we were doing like a
crazy involved sketch I would go I want
to figure out how to do this on iMovie
so that way I can tell people I did this
because people will be like would you
edit this one it's great I bet it was
iMovie that way to show that you can
make it happen with the most beginner
program but now I don't do them anymore
now it's everything's uh at least on
Final Cut but start if what advice start
everyone says I wish I'd start it sooner
everybody says that and I feel that way
and I'm full time and still be like man
but what if I'd started like I started
right as there was a boom happening
about six seven years ago but what if
I'd started and had traction right
before that and then what we just said
before and the other part about if you
want to grow you have to find your own
voice your own style your own place that
you add value I think you just gotta
treat it like a playground in the
beginning
try a lot of stuff I've been people
spend way too much time overthinking how
they're going to launch their glorious
Channel and I'm like don't do that like
seriously you don't know I didn't start
thinking I'm gonna be the ranking guy a
year and I went wait a minute when I
review movies I get 100 views when I do
a ranking I get 500 views I'm not a
genius 500 is more than 100 right let's
double down on that like we provide a
lot of commentary but I found out like
oh okay well I could break we broke
through with the what I was trying to do
the reaction so I was like all right
let's give the reaction and it'll
provide all the commentary after right
after the reaction yeah so I've still
found my way to do the reviews but it's
like it's in the form of introducing
first to the reaction
um so yeah you just figure it out over
time Johnny
Sean
got a question for you how about you
doing a ranking of all Stanley Kubrick's
movies and how about real rejects do
reactions to each one I would love to
watch 2001 A Space Odyssey I haven't
seen it I feel like it might be boring
what do you think is it boring Jen
you haven't seen it
is boring uh I've seen enough it's been
a long time to know that the Barbie
trailer was riffing off of it right away
but I wanted to see the Barbie movie
that was fun I should play that trailer
for my daughter and she's like what is
going on nine years old like what is
this like what you haven't seen 2001 A
Space Odyssey you're not my daughter
what is this like what you know nothing
so unsophisticated
but I I haven't watched it in 20 years
have you seen every Stanley Cooper I
have not I mean I've seen probably half
of them he's on a different wavelength
for me you haven't seen The Shining of
course I've seen The Shining Full Metal
Jacket
um
was it the killing is what I read a book
from Quentin Tarantino of like 100
movies you got to watch and and the
killing was like 1955 so watch that one
um so I've seen like five of them six of
them so the problem is like a ranking
works when you release it tied to
something else June movie comes out so
you ride that wave everyone's interested
in that director interested in that
franchise you drop it at that point in
time and so you have to think about a
perspective of watching 13 movies this
is 26 hours for one video because I
don't I don't rank Things based off old
memories
Sean I think this is the way we should
do the stream okay this is I think uh
watches Jennifer you can just poke your
head just way out there
[Laughter]
I'm fixing it guys I'm fixing it hold on
there we go whoa whoa what happened
oh I'm fixing it I'm fixing everyone
calm down
this is actually this is the preferred
method
what is happening right now I can't
figure it out I don't know Sean oh my
God I'm moving it I'm at least moving it
I'm doing it Sean
hey oh there we go oh yeah
that's what I'm talking about
I got it I got it everyone
Sean what time you gotta bounce that's a
good question wrong question Jen what
time do you guys
it's true I don't know
uh see us we have to no we have other
person with us and I'm meeting uh Tessa
oh I'm a good Mama's geek you know she
has still not come over here
really yeah well now I feel special well
it looks like or mama's been rejecting
you Mama's geek he's the next person
who's gonna come on the stream now
I love Mama's geeky she's amazing she's
a great woman so this might be my first
time meeting her in person you haven't
met her in person she's great she's
amazing yeah so we're both at Star Wars
celebration in May and we were like
trying to message each other and but I
was staying in Burbank which is nowhere
close
I have no clue
um and um yeah she was like staying at
the hotel right there and so it just it
just didn't work out
sorry for that uncomfortable lean you
got to do what time are we at what yeah
all right
we'll try to end this by two o'clock
okay that sounds good does that sound
fair Jen
I think that feels like what my brain
was okay I had no way my luck will be
like much later so try and answer quick
which won't happen
when I when I get to the point about I
feel the urgency I'll make it happen
um anyway where are we at here are you
guys enjoying the stream if you haven't
left a like yet please go ahead and
leave a like please for the love of God
do it
Sean tell them yeah well he's got four
cats that need to be fed with clever
names I know uh and you got like copper
four children Watson
Sherlock
other reference to the fox
your wife remembers Jen remembers he
said the names I was like oh what random
names and she's like that's great that's
amazing what what's going on what your
random names though sorry the [__] in
the head like oh oh yeah
um let's go here uh I know we got more
Super tests we will get no no no Condor
don't worry I'm we're gonna get back to
the super chest I just like to check in
with the with the I don't know what to I
feel like you say regular chat that
sounds diminishing help me come up with
a better word
I want to check out Jen says peasants
with the non-contributors to the
fortunes of the fame
[Laughter]
I want to check in with just a regular
chat here the normal one no trust me we
will get to the super chats we'll get
there
um do we read Batman books only the
novels would never pick up a Batman
comic book uh did I read uh I've been
reading manga lately I've I've been
reading Attack on Titan yeah let's go
back to the live chat here that's
actually great that's all we gotta say
exactly what it's called the live thank
you everyone
sit right there on the street yeah it's
called the live chat right in front of
us and it says it right there
anyway sorry guys the regulars the
normies
um the rejects oh there's a lot of great
there's a lot of great comments here uh
I'm reading my I I've made it terrible
do you watch any anime at all not really
my buddy Andy's really trying to get me
into it so I think there's like a Demon
Slayer coming out this week so he's
gonna try and take me to it and then my
son because of fortnite is discovering
things so he's like Dragon Ball because
they brought Dragon Ball into fortnite
so then he's like Dragon Ball he watched
one they put one episode in fortnite
and then he was like wanted more and
said can we get Crunchyroll I don't know
what it is can we get it's like
how do you even know about this I think
Dragon Ball's on there okay so it's been
fun but uh not not so much I think uh
trying to think of what your taste might
like yeah I haven't seen a carry yet
I've seen that I haven't seen it so I
wanted to read it first yeah so I
started watching in high school some
friends were watching but I started
halfway through it in the first sequence
I saw they were like teddy bears
attacking people and then they get
punched the teddy bird oh my God milk
starts to pour out of it then there's a
huge amoeba it's like
uh
what am I watching it's like jumped in
like the worst moment in time
um I'm on uh Attack on Titan Attack on
Titan
that's why I'm reading now so I can
learn how to read uh Attack on Titan is
returning with its final season and I
had this goal
that I was like you know what I think
I'm gonna read all of Attack on Titan
before leading into because manga
adaptations tend to be pretty faithful
so I was like I'm gonna re I wanted to
get a refresher as opposed to
re-watching hours of Television I was
like I just want to read it and I'm
going to read the Manga up to where we
left off in the show
and that goal has given me quite a lot
of anxiety because now I'm like I have
so much to reach yeah in the next few
days and uh I was kind of one of the
reasons about I finished my work around
like 1 30 in the morning and I was like
oh but I got it I gotta I gotta read
some more because the show comes out in
a week yeah
um so but yeah no I've been loving uh I
feel like it helps spark the imagination
uh funny enough actually you know like
it's funny with comics and graphic
novels that there's often the
association that it's less of a form
because it's not just pure literature uh
but there are a lot of studies that have
been shown that there are a lot of
equally been like equally beneficial
ways for your brain to develop if you do
like I know a lot of authors who like
didn't grow up on them and stuff so I
actually do think that hey man if you
have a hard time reading novels read
some graphics read some Comics well I
mean it's just even the elitism of like
what has to be like if you're like my
kid is sitting there reading anything
that's better than him sitting there
watching
yeah that's inherently better and so
funny enough watching TV movies is the
least effective thing right but like
playing a video game it's more effective
right yeah that's the funny part about
it a lot of these things that people
call laziness but no no they actually
can't help with brain development but
yeah read Comics guys I think they are
it's good for the brain webs thank you
so much people reads backward in Japan
that can be confusing I forgot about
that for a second
uh most badass seen in any movie uh I
think John Wick's scene is uh is great
uh the the first scene that's still my
favorite of John Wick of them all what
do you feel about the John Wick run time
that's very long huh yeah so my
test screening guy has seen it they love
it uh pretty much he says yeah yeah look
you know just just as solid as the other
ones so long they and I don't like part
of the appeal the first was the brevity
of it but he said it moves really quick
I don't know if I believe him but they
they did two different endings for the
movie they had two screen computers and
each theater had a different ending
shown to him
wow so make of that as you will it's
crazy how that started off with just a a
solid just focused yeah simple movement
how dare you kill my dog I'm coming to
get you and then now it's it's like
massive world it's like traveling the
desert and cutting off his fingers
it's taken it has taken an evolution
foreign
what about my voice Batman
oh yes
I do um I do believe that
um I'm just going to look at my text
messages
that's fair that's fair
cool Lego man says have you played the
Arkham games oh yeah I I've played the
first three Pokemon the Batmobile in
Arkham Knight I couldn't do the
Batmobile mechanics all right I'm gonna
refresh this okay here's what we're
gonna do I got this i got this shot I'm
gonna make sure we stay on track okay
because Sean's if Sean said we got to be
out of here by two I'd be like don't
worry Sean I got you but in my Noggin
I'm like I'm making this 2 30. for when
the Mrs says two I go I better make sure
we're done by 1 59 PM I respect this
yeah
I live in fear every week
and like I said this is her angry board
whoa you can't defend yourself if you
don't have a microphone do you want the
mic we are pressuring you that's what
we're doing
if you had the mic we wouldn't have to
sail we wouldn't have to pressure you
sorry Chad I got this all right I got
this we're gonna catch up on our supers
and Scoot into the middle oh yes we can
do this now I always feel better when
I'm closer to you
I feel
ambivalent
that's fair that's fair I get that a lot
we got this hold on I'm going I'm going
oh okay we're almost there yeah we're
almost there
Kubrick here we go Condor seven two one
five thank you Modoc makes me feel some
kind of way I actually liked Modoc a lot
of people
don't like him I liked him I thought he
was fun Sean thoughts he made me laugh
but I I just like putting him next to
Kang just it felt like
they're from two different movies two
different directors because it's it's
like such a serious villain with such a
silly villain sharing scenes together
and then without going into spoilers
since someone over here hasn't watched
the movie yet
um I mean you're in the finale and it's
like trying to do big Stakes danger and
then it's like don't be a dick but I can
just cuts like just this silly like that
I wasn't feeling any I have no strong
feelings for quantumania so because of
that when it got to that moment I wasn't
bothered yeah because I was like I
already don't feel much of anything
happening right now so I'm like at least
it's amusing yeah yeah it did make he
did make me laugh he was a funny guy
v900
so are the DC animated film reactions
done then I'm having Coy and John react
to the DC anime because I haven't seen a
lot of them I know you said the views
were changing it up it was fine with Coy
and John at least getting Justice League
Gods and Monsters and Conor quits it's
so good no they're not quitting it up no
they're not quitting they're not no no
no as a matter of fact
um uh we re they will they will continue
on the linear path but once in a while I
like to throw a wrench in their gears
and throw them a new bone and so I had
them cover one that I actually think is
good and not enough people talk about
Batman versus the Ninja Turtles that's a
great way to mix it I own it but I
haven't watched it yet watch it it's fun
and I got kids
man watch it yeah kids love Yeah
Donatello
Raphael
Leonardo Michael Angelo I remember 3D
films look we finally got to his
comments yes finally here's what he said
glad to know I'm not alone and noticing
Sean's iconic pose in this thumbnail
sweet collab guys thank you 3C films and
this is his pose for reviews
[Laughter]
you notice that right
he's off to the such a great way to get
people to click Like Cocaine bear is dot
dot dot yeah
this review
I need to know now what you think
that's smart that's good next time we
got to do the pose together yeah Chris
you gotta you gotta do the pose and he's
got to do the yeah this is each of our
iconic things
I know I know we want to spend like 45
minutes an answer but we just can't
afford that right now Daniel Skinner
thank you for the Super Chat greetings
gentlemen we have come to the one year
anniversary Sean's first watching of the
Lost Boys what are Greg's thoughts on
the film well I'll tell you guys I'll
tell well Sean what did you think
um I actually watched it at Cody Leach's
house for the first time when I was at
his house and he's like and it's one of
his favorite movies so since I was there
he like could force me to watch it and
so finally sat down and watch it and
it's
um as a very
flavorful film that's right that's just
so nice for Cody the song I still played
the song from it all the time when I'm
editing videos and I'll play the oh
shall not whatever that song is I don't
know the lyrics I haven't seen it yeah I
still haven't seen it maybe I'll do a
reaction to it I did watch Jennifer's
Body recently oh yeah that was fun it
plays it says sounds a little bit
different when there's a Jennifer right
there and yeah I watched that wasn't you
look at your wife's body recently
there was like a hesitation and you
looked up at me and I was like oh are
they like fans
but
yeah
there's quite a few things in the lost
boys that are very reactable like
there's a part where there's like this
big bodybuilder guy playing a saxophone
oh nice like gyrating it is so 80s I
think I wanna I love vampires what do
you think Joel Schumacher so the guy
that you know applied a bag of tricks to
Batman that probably wasn't the best bag
of tricks to apply there but yeah it's
but it's it's interesting he's done some
good movies yeah absolutely
phone booth man
um
A Time to Kill the like he did that
movie like and he did like I think he
did it sandwiched between this two
Batman films like let's bat nipples
serious courtroom drama about racism bat
nipples that's amazing Schumacher man
yeah Jim we're gonna be at on the time
oh
[Laughter]
linger forever D Murdock
thank you Dee hey
how hyped are you for Daredevil born
again I'm super hyped but a bit worried
we're looking forward to the showing
anything John bernthal's Punisher will
return possibly Midnight Sun I am hyped
for Daredevil Born Again however
definitely nervous I am I am nervous for
it because yeah of all the reasons
you've heard yeah I mean they're gonna
PG-13 and up I know that's not
everything I have heard I've had this
discussion a lot of people don't like to
hear me out on it I do think the
violence though is a part of the world
right to remove it's like when you go
from Expendables one and two to three
you're like I know you don't really need
the blood and gore but it's part of the
world so now I'm like aware of it
especially when you're if they were
starting over with a new new actors I
would not notice it right I feel like
I'm gonna be a little bit aware of it
now it's such a point of reference but
it's been so much time with and it does
contribute to the emotional response and
reaction to moments like the head
smashing scene is a big part out of this
something yeah and so to completely I
don't know how far they'll push but I
don't know you know like I've been
watching them I I rewatched the
Mandalorian because season three's
coming out that's what we're doing right
now and I was and sometimes I am
surprised by like like in the in the
Boba Fett episode with the Mandalorian
when it first shows up he's like slicing
and dicing them even there's no blood
and stuff I'm like this is a lot more
violent than I remember it being so
maybe we can go a little far I don't
know yeah I it's it's tougher to for me
to not be very nervous Daredevil is
probably my favorite show of the last
decade it's my favorite of he's my
favorite character from the MCU and I
mean I mean I just loved that show all
the seasons right I mean she can tell
you this like I rewatched season two all
the Punisher stuff like unloop and she's
like you have a problem you need to quit
Daredevil like this is this is going too
far and
but when I think like
joining these Disney plus and I look at
the consistency of the quality of the
Disney Plus shows and in the the writing
team isn't returning right it's a new
writing team and they're pulling in
arrowverse people and I just go those
aren't I think really
like are you are you I'm excited to get
some arrowverse people to write it was
like
you are dramatically misreading what I
liked about the universe
but yeah I'm I'm nervous I would love to
be proven wrong I would I would I would
even if it's really punishers the one
I'm like I just don't think they could
do Pottery like Punisher is so violent
it's just like that prison sequence in
the hallway yes
he's just covered in blood yeah that
doesn't feel like uh
Disney material even even the adult side
of Disney plus but it's strange because
they do have the Netflix shows on Disney
plus now would and they haven't
diminished the violence there so but
when you're when you're announcing like
new show on Disney plus I'm like I think
they might though who knows let's see
let's see how bold they are regardless
everything comes down to emotion
storytelling blah blah blah that's the
part I'm most concern if anything I'm
more concerned about that than anything
else because they do have 18 episodes
and um yeah we'll see we'll see uh but
yeah I think I think we will get the
midnight Suns eventually especially now
they've got blade coming into the mix
they're nothing but good things about
blade
right
it's been nothing but good news about
this movie yeah yeah there's no trouble
on the production
Lee said best Marvel movie ever I'm glad
I called feige that's the quote quote me
condor7215. while I have an intuition
for the super Channel I haven't enjoyed
the Marvel shows I haven't really
disliked any of the movies I understand
the criticism I'm just not invested
after end game
yeah that's a fair way to put it
um I feel like the fomo is missing I've
had so many conversations with people
that leading up to end game they saw
everything and then with so many TV
shows coming out it just broke the
ability for people to watch everything
and so then just that that fear that
you're not you're gonna not gonna catch
something it's just gone and there's not
something to replace it to give us that
it's an urgency it's a big commitment
too when you're asking everyone to watch
like eight to ten hours television
versus watch this one movie we have
coming right and you're still having
three movies plus five TV shows every
time a new movie comes up people keep
asking me like which shows do I need to
watch what's what's the bare minimum I
need to watch people to understand this
that's the conversation now
Loki yes Loki's the one
Jen do you need a stand
do you walk like a walk or a cartwheel
you do a Chinese get up at some point
try a Gainer I want you to run and try
and do a backflip
we're just answering a random question
that's where the super chats are going
to the hospital
these five dollars are for Sean don't
take any if you're correct we're just
gonna move past this Super Chat really
quick he loves another one yeah yeah I
did I Like Cocaine beers we could think
these things Contour because I'm
basically cocaine bear he is just like
me wow condra that's a real I've never
connected more with a character than the
cocaine pair it's the Barrett character
no well I mean I don't want to get too
much into spoilers but no
she doesn't start talking now no no it's
just a Slaughter machine yeah I mean
it's an animal there's only one thing
you can really do with an animal to to
develop does it feel like it overstays
its welcome
I mean it's the opposite you feel like
there's there's stretches in the middle
of it where you're like
where's the bear
oh really yeah okay that's the issue
not enough of the bear yeah like it
starts off when you get like a a an
early Bear kill and then it has to
there's a lot of characters and so it
spends all this time establishing the
police this family and they're going
hiking and it's drug dealers and you're
like
where's the bear so it's just not as
interesting as the Bear right so the
bear stuff's the best part but it's not
but the other stuff they supplement okay
yeah I mean like if you if you did like
a super if you found a way to super cut
it into like 30 minutes of the bear just
tearing people up it's funny yeah watch
a bear snort there's the ambulance
sequence in it gnarly kills like there's
some stuff that happens that you're like
it's just quincing and cringing at it
because it's so painful like in the good
way did you watch it Jen Jenny didn't
watch it you didn't take your kids uh
well so I saw it uh here in town at the
Burbank 16 and then she after the movie
I went to pick her up from the airport
it's been a wild weekend of like she'll
take your kids to go watch co-cams they
love animals
yeah please send me the therapy Bill I'm
moving
Bronson plays hey buddy you aspiring
Philadelphia hey guys hey Brunson uh we
know Sean loves Daredevil would you all
want to react to our Punisher versus
Daredevil short film if not that's
perfectly fine stay awesome well John
Humphrey and I did a reaction to your
short film I've sent it to you
exclusively but yeah Sean you should
look up Bronson plays and watch the
short film he's an aspiring filmmaker a
lot of work into that well worth the
time
thank you brought to place for
mentioning that but yeah I did an
exclusive reaction just for Bronson
because he's contributed so much here
dead shot you heard the rumors Spidey
leading Avengers King Dynasty we did we
did and I think Tom Holland should lead
it alongside Miss Marvel I think that
would be a fun day actually I didn't
even think about that they'd be a great
on-screen chemistry wouldn't they
uh you don't want to like that you don't
like Miss Marvel uh well what's turning
red shot
let's get to turning red
um I really like the stuff when it was
in her neighborhood I felt like it was
they then matched season two into the
middle of the season and it goes
globetrotting and all the backstory
about the powers I felt like season one
should have just been her learning to
use her powers and earning respect in
the community uh and so I felt like both
of those got underdeveloped I was like
really digging the first two episodes
and the style to it and then I liked the
last episode
um and it just felt like they had to
rush too much in the middle so you're
saying when they showed no more white
people is when you lost your interest
Sean is that it's I'm pretty sure that's
what you said
I mean that's what I meant
Jennifer how do you feel your kids are
watching right Jen agrees oh my gosh
like that's exactly well Jen oh my I
should mute you
I have not checked the streamlabs oh no
we have stream Labs I did not advertise
that I will check the stream labs to see
and once I get through this round here
I'm Gonna Keep Us on check here yeah we
gotta go fast
Stephen Jenkins thank you the Crossovers
knew we needed but never thought I'd get
it y'all are the best Hey Stephen you're
the best whoa you're the best Stephen
Jenkins your name looks like Stephen
Hawkins if I didn't have glasses
[Laughter]
is that the offensive should Marvel
break from Disney their content seems
too childish and I believe it's Disney
recently get into childish and it
restricts seriousness
I saw an interesting thesis from a
channel called the Cabernet okay that
was about wokeness did not ruin Marvel
it is capitalism that ruined them
capitalism okay
I haven't heard the video out yet but it
sounds like an interesting thought
happened here but I think it's because
of like the amount of consumption and
content where things have become diluted
I'm assuming that's what the video is
about I have not seen it so I cannot
speak on it but I like a good title like
that that makes me go fascinating
um yeah uh I I think
I mean no Marvel's not going to break
from Disney who's gonna like I mean
anyone will clamor to take them but the
ones who could afford Marvel from them I
just think they got to take their time a
little bit more that's the main thing
yeah I mean it takes your time there was
two phases of
with Disney that we weren't saying oh
Disney ruined everything yeah
now Disney's clearly ruining everything
people were very reactionary right the
world's reaction social media YouTube
comments you know people could love me
one day and then I do one thing wrong
like say I hate this part in this Marvel
because there's no whities and then
suddenly everyone turns on them
that's true that's true
make a little comment about uh turning
red
you understand it's called satire people
for crying out loud people better get it
Condor 7215 my Ant-Man experience oh
thank you for such a generous Super Chat
by the way my Ant-Man experience was
weird my friend and I were the only
people in the theater and he would not
stop talking about Michelle Pfeiffer's
truck what the hell
which is confusing to me because he only
likes men
wow what is this comment I don't know I
was weird I did have a dream that
involved meeting Michelle Pfeiffer and
telling her like you were such an
underrated talent and I was like part of
my dream was talking to her being like
you are so amazing and no one gives you
enough credit that was part of my weird
dream that I had but in it she was also
like returning as Catwoman yeah which is
what I would like I think that'd be cool
if they did keep micro Keating around
and they brought back Michelle Pfeiffer
and you did get to see old man Batman
and old woman Catwoman and then both of
them would currently be in the MCU
how cool would that be you ever go watch
re-watch movies from like 2003 and
realize everyone in everything from 20
years ago is now a superhero yeah we
want 13 going on 30. and you go through
the the cast of it Jennifer Garner Rock
Ruffalo Andy Circus oh yes Judy Greer
movies yeah he's just going through it
like yep yep yep yep true
it's a good movie 13 going on 30. I like
those you know I'm 17 Again love that
movie you've seen 17 is this the one
with the ffron oh Mike I've only seen it
once but I like because why would I
watch that but I really liked it it was
amazing as I was like I don't even
remember why we watched it was like this
is
I shouldn't be I'm 30 why am I enjoying
that I don't have to affect him like I
thought this was just for like teen
girls yeah but this is doing it for me
I love that movie that was great well
sorry about that weird experience but
Michelle Pfeiffer is very attractive
Jennifer and I were talking about that a
little bit we're Michelle Pfeiffer
called her a silver fox or something
like that she part of your guys's card
your five people card of friends she's
not on your five she's not on the five
people is pretty snow on your your card
real story we're walking we're at the
Hollywood critics
we're walking to the bathroom
my wife is very afraid of celebrities
like they're in the room we're talking
to people they're like I just talk this
person goes it's freaking out other
people talking to celebrities we're
walking down the hall and she just sees
like this girl in front of us to just
just
looks really nice so she just walks up
to her puts touches around and goes you
look stunning if you walk
thanks we walked three more steps she
goes oh crap that was Brittany Snow no
way she
she intently
it's done while touching her arm to
Brittany Snow
that's amazing yeah
so apparently Britney Stones is uh is
her type you remember that Bernie snow
well she's a very beautiful woman
she's very beautiful
you are stunning
don't take it back I just oh
I wish I had time do you guys know the
singer Christine Milian
no the
she was in the movie the follow-up to
get shorty
it's not be short let's go be cool we
have The Rock in it yeah
there's a whole no I don't know if that
is
maybe maybe if there's time but remind
me later
lots of a philosophical way of life
that's a great story appreciate that
Brittany Snow she's in the movie X I
think we're Marvel Studios failure began
Marvel's wow Marvel's really taken an
interesting trajectory and yeah Marvel's
that's the I think the word is strong
feelings like no one's really degenerate
there's not a lot of strong hate for
anything there's not a lot of strong
love for anything right and so that
feeling makes it the most unintery like
during the live event I said it's
ant-man's the most
um
divisive in the most dull way yeah
because there's no strong feelings of
that like I can talk with someone and be
like I don't really like it and someone
who like loves it but they don't love it
to the degree where they're gonna really
be on it it's not like and and I feel
like at least if they made strong
feelings then then it would still be a
super strong conversation that's where I
looked at like the rotten did a video on
the Rotten Tomatoes score and how it was
so low and it was all like five out of
tens like it's one of the lowest for the
MCU but it's the positives are a six out
of ten the negatives are a four or five
out of ten it's like everybody's like
right there it's just like yeah
there's like the feeling for it and and
I think Marvel just needs to regenerate
like a consistency of strong feelings
I'm one of the P it doesn't seem like
it's a truly as consistent across the
board for me I was one of the people who
did love wakanda I really did I really
had an effect on me personally but but I
don't feel like it did we can't dissect
what is that I like did it reflect
normal common people and experiences who
just happen to have abilities everybody
shouldn't know who they are and or have
powers it doesn't kind of need to get
back to a little bit more of the you
know like saving people yeah out of five
instead of just a general we saved the
world right but having an uh even with
Kang Dynasty that's a big in the comics
that's a big part of when kings like uh
you know attacking earth a lot of it
involves like we have to save the heroes
even Age of Ultron kind of gets that you
know right of like well ultron's
attacking you know well I mean to the
Miss Marvel conversation as well as with
Moon Knight
they don't do a lot of normal superhero
stuff it gets into this globetrotting
adventure yes and that's where kind of
both shows I was like I would have liked
to have seen Moon Knight be Moon Knight
doing superhero stuff rather than
exploring like the world yes and then
with Miss Marvel it was like as soon as
they start to set her up to be friendly
neighborhood Miss Marvel then she
travels the world yeah and so we lost
that thing that was like oh this is and
they set up this idea of like how are
people responding in a community with
social media and then they do a plot
that doesn't really expand on that until
we get to the finale exactly and so it's
it's losing that basic superhero stuff
for going big and we need videos the
foundation
Strife Greg Hazard movie Project radios
what does that mean
that's a th
Jennifer use social media for a living
yes thanks Patrick we didn't we didn't
skip fragirl did we this is how like
we're I'm gonna go to the top here and
then I'll tell you if we skipped you
I'll I'll control it
well yeah anyway oh
yeah
there's a lot of things that have been
up in the air I've had one script
sometimes you you get a script done and
then a studio gets it
and then it just never gets created and
that's the that's the that's most
screenplays what do you find out but I
as of this week
I I can't talk about it
I can't talk about it but there's
something
that is better that I completed and I
collaborated with some people who
literally have
God I wish I could
they've done stuff that I know a lot of
you have seen like I'm talking behind
the like actual directory and and and I
did a script with yeah okay but now it's
gonna go through it's a whole thing and
that one I've just been really
tight-lipped on because I don't want
this kind of question to come back I
just basically want it to be like all
right once it's done and once it's like
like okay now let's make an official
announcement I want it to be like a
deadline situation yeah remember see
freaking we got right to you you said we
skipped you uh which which is a bigger
gamble in the comic book films mcu's
middle age or dcu's reboot
um the bigger gamble dcu's reboot uh I
don't think any of them are a bigger I
don't know if the word Gamble's the
right word I think that the reboot is a
lot more interesting it's been easy for
me but we're hopeful for the DCU because
they went this isn't working let's try
something new so I go oh I want to give
that a chance but I look at the MCU and
I go it feels I feel like you're making
some of the same mistakes and you're
drifting away from some of the stuff
that I love a little bit and I don't
have as much of that bad excitement that
I had before there's not a thing that
I'm specifically like oh this could be
yeah and so I'm more excited for DCU but
I mean
well I think the MCU can easily just
tweak a few things and you're right
you're back on right correct like I know
it sounds easier said than done that's
really what it comes down to is there
seems to be a consistent thing that
people are saying so
just fix patch those holes up and you're
good uh DCU is like we need to work with
what we have before and do a whole new
thing simultaneous they have a much
bigger challenge so if we're gonna talk
about gamble that that's more of the
gamble especially when they're like we
got 11 we got 11 projects we're going to
tell you about
10 minute warning uh-oh you're nowhere
near done okay I have an idea I have an
idea all right because look Sean I am
not one of those YouTubers yeah who ends
who ends a stream without without
completing all the super chat yeah
gotcha because they're Fair they're
channels that don't even read their
super chats I know shame on them shame
sometimes I go on their Channels with
shame on them
you bet they're not watching
they're not watching so let's do one
more okay here's what I'm gonna do
everyone I gotta fix this right now
I'm going to disable
the ability to contribute to the super
chats
we should do that in the future well
this guy's a genius
one time it took me I was I was on my
stream for like six hours I was like
wait a minute
it's such a hard thing because it's such
a massive topic I'm like oh we've been
here for six hours but it's a weird
thing to do because it's like all right
I'm gonna make it so you guys can't pay
me money to ask questions I like it when
you pay me money these don't have the
greatest playback so the super chats
really do help and yeah no this this
does help
um it it is it is actually a a very
big contribution for these and they're
fun to do but you know
you Bronson please didn't get that hold
on a sec this is not refreshing I'm just
trying to refresh the um everything and
then I'm gonna re we're going to read
through it
please stop yelling Jen yeah I'm trying
to get your husband out of here on time
I'm trying my best right now Jen
do you want my sweater
if you don't want to be on camera I
totally understand but can your hand be
on camera can you hand me that and I
will hand you I will hand I'm going to
get you out of here at 2 10. I promise
but I have to show everyone that or at
least Sean you can you can grab that I
just got this from that extends
Maria Hammond I wanted to wear this on
an upcoming just specific Marvel stream
Maria Hammond got me the cloak of
levitation feel that you can you can
wear it too it keeps you warm I
literally have it on my chair that I add
that I entered on
have it there all the time I already did
it to use and so yeah I mean it does
butt in here but I I always I haven't
gotten fast enough at buttoning it
that's why I'm not gonna do it but it
does button perfectly and it's great so
yeah oh this would have been great to
have the whole stream what the hell was
I thinking oh and check it out we got a
new real rejects last of a shirt that I
haven't promoted it's a real rejects
exclusives
[Music]
surprise the surprise do you want this
it'll keep you warm
now if only we can develop a technology
where it could just float to her
I'm I'm expecting you to have that next
time I stop by there's a big assumption
oh open the door without it
Mr Chandler
um
really low sound what what sounds all
low okay oh yeah okay all right all
right let me let me check on the stream
labs
I forgot about that because I didn't
plug it but we do got we do got we just
got one I'm just gonna read it out loud
all right so I'm so awesome face thank
you hey Greg and Sean so sad I couldn't
make it to the live show would love to
meet all you guys shame on you you
should have paid 25 and bought a two
item Min a month and driven all the way
out there that's the way I meet people I
only bought
soda while I was there and they let you
get away with it I I don't know I didn't
understand the system how are they
supposed to be checking me on that
you con artists
game the system one percent over here
hope you guys only paid admission it
only bought one drink not two hope you
guys decided to do another one
what do you guys think about replacing
loveness as the writer for Kang Dynasty
I think he'd be fine much love that's
the thing with these movies you know a
lot of blame can go like it's the
director or it's the screenwriter
there's it's a writer's room there's
there's such a massive Cog piece and all
kinds of movie like it's not like they
said oh this is what he wrote we gotta
go I 100 guarantee you a lot of people
made changes on that [__] without him
being the one to have a say or a final
say or something like that when it comes
to the the bigger the movie is the less
that you're watching the screenwriters
original screenplay that's just the way
it goes it is the trajectory of how it
is
um so yeah who wrote end game the guys
that wrote Thor the Dark World as well
as the worst of the Narnia movies like
that it that's especially like the guy
that wrote this hit Last of Us show also
wrote hangover two and three yes yeah
great Craig amazing I didn't know that
like they wrote like all those spoof
movies
such a like like lowest of low comedies
yes harsh turn to turn Noble yeah
guys leave a like for Craig Mason
um and I believe in the director Destiny
the the Lord of the Rings new movie I
don't know what's going on with that we
gotta finish the Super Chat I don't know
what's going on the Lord of the Rings
new movie that sounds weird to me right
uh that rings of power to not do it for
me
that was rough Jennifer what did you
think of rings of power yeah Jen what do
you think of rings of power
really slow
that's true that is not wrong
she said wife she's never wrong yeah
that's true
that's right even when she's clearly
wrong yeah she's never wrong because
marriage advice right there
I learned a lot I don't know I've heard
so much marriage advice and here's what
I've come to learn it's all true
it's all 100 true I was like you know
because like we were if and I we've been
together for like six years so I had
enough time to be like I already know
what I got to be like for all right here
we go
always in the wrong all right we're
going to wrap this up we don't have too
much left okay
what's our time Jen
all right all right yeah
all right okay all right yeah we're
gonna do this guys leave a like please
for the love of God leave a like
seriously what are you doing leave a
like
I got this I'm pulling it up boom
shakalaka
Sean thank you for being here thanks for
inviting me this I reached out to be
like hey let's continue our deep dark
conversation you're like yeah let's do a
live stream we're talking about Marvel
movies how about you just come on the
stream goddamn
or instead of trudging up Old Wounds
we'll talk about comic book movies
I've had so many it stemmed out of like
I wanted to put up a video today that
didn't get done and I was like but you
know if you want to do a live stream
because you're here I am and so I mean
did you enjoy it do you regret it uh I
am actually just thrilled to have this
opportunity so truly we've been very
silly
I just thank you so much it really does
mean a lot okay
um it's cool to just meet you cool to
hang out that we have had a a serious
conversation and now we're having
another conversation we should have had
yesterday this is normally
um
does he seem like he's enjoying himself
like genuinely okay
more than the first time he was with
Cody
she doesn't know she doesn't know is he
liking more than Cody now are you like
what would you rank me
you got to do Reiki my YouTuber yeah
these are great ideas I got it I got I
got topics
I had to be real Rejects and Sean
Chandler greatest crossover yeah you
hear that I don't see a Cody in there
Cody
where's your name Cody
uh I I I was a little late discovering
Cody
um his Dexter coverage yes that was he
was the first one I found and I and I
followed that religiously with uh the
last season that was uh he really echoed
my thoughts yeah I was like devastated
at the end once again yeah
well my decks are experience like I
don't cover Dexter on this channel but
like I love the original series I felt
like all right after bringing it back
maybe they're going to do it did you
watch it oh yeah yeah
yeah that ending was I was like how they
how'd they top themselves right they're
doing it worse like it was on the right
path yes I was so upset yeah I I
couldn't believe I was I was shocked
like I don't understand how you had this
much time and then you bought you and
especially when your show is known for
the words yeah and for a long time I
wondered like was one of the reasons
like did I love the Breaking Bad finale
so much is because it was a week after
the Dexter finale that was so bad like
what was it really I didn't I didn't
watch Dexter while it was airing yeah it
was one week apart and so it was like
how did they get this so wrong and then
one week later you're like you watch
Breaking Bad is like they did it they
did it and then yeah they have like
eight years to come up with a better
Landing wow yeah
the worst of all things they could do
still upsets me yeah I thought it was a
terrible ending terrible
I was like there's a way they could have
got into that ending without it being
terrible by them everything felt like
what these don't decisions don't make
any difference yeah that was so stupid
gosh Dexter you let me down again
um philosophical way of life background
the secret sauce to Marvel success was
actually John Favreau and the Russo Bros
Marvel should go with authenticity and
realism little to no foolish comedy I
don't know if authenticity and real is
it there's a certain sense of grounded
um
itude is that the word that they talk
about a believable world what the hell
that's a word yeah
look up versamillitude please Robert
Meyer Burnett apparently uses it a lot
we don't mention RMB over here well then
so in the special features from Superman
the movie Richard Donner Richard Donner
used the word versamillitude yeah
the appearance of being true or real and
so even if it's something that's not
real to our world it feels real to their
world right and so then when you watch
Kang show up and it's like a stretched
face yeah yeah oh this doesn't look real
to anywhere enough fair enough oh yeah
no I think that is no we gotta steal
that
and never credit Robert Byron brunette
so I had to credit him because people
started accusing me of ripping off
because I used the word one time as if
you probably remember that's the only
way I invented the language and
legitimately Like Richard Donner used it
to describe his that's what he was
trying to do and it's a great word uh if
for what makes some of these movies
better than some of the other ones but
um yeah I was not ripping off Robert
Meyer Burnett I've watched the special
features with Richard Donner a lot and
your content Leaf that's what we call
you around here
that's the best excuse I have for why I
ripped off Robert Meyer Burnett Tyler
Bennett he's just saying thank you
despite Quantum Mania still excited for
Guardian three absolutely I I think
there's a few there's few films in the
in Quantum in that Quantum and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe where it
really feels like this is the director's
movie yeah I think that's why people
were still excited for Thor love and
thunder leading records are like it's
Taiko YTD they let tiger do his thing
and Guardians has this
has a separate like it's obviously still
feels MCU but it really feels like James
guns Guardians of the Galaxy 3. not even
not even quantumania when you're looking
at it you're like Peyton reads and man
like you're not even thinking that
leading into it it feels like MCU
product yeah certain ones and even like
in uh Doctor Strange there was the
samurai museums right and then there was
the generic MCU isms too yeah but like
you look at Guardians it just looks like
Guardians and the holiday special that
made me remember how much I love these
characters
philosophical way of life Marvel made
billions of dollars didn't stop being
cheap
he pension using newbie Riders directors
and actors recirculate those billions
keep in mind when the the russos that
you just praised when they brought them
in they were they directed you me and
Dupree as a movie
they had and they were working on
community yeah Caruso's the most
celebrated they were recruited
by comparison it didn't make any sense
to hire them yeah so they haven't really
changed their policy but if you go from
needing to recruit three people per year
to recruiting
six seven eight because they're TV shows
that you it's tougher to find this
perfect picks true true but um I I don't
think I don't like these movies still
cost 300 million dollars but I think the
money's going to the wrong details and
wrong stuff movies take time they they
take time so when you got that much
quantity yeah that's what I mean it's
like and it seems like you know when 5G
was first announced and how much you're
going to be doing there was a concern
yeah and but I I didn't have that
concern but now I'm like okay now I see
what people were concerned because
because I think feige's involvement in
Creative producer had definitely needs
when you're when he's focusing one
project at a time now it's like I need
to focus on like 40 Projects at a time
well you said the secret sauce is those
other guys I mean feige is the secret
sauce so if you've got one guy that's
shepherding two movies per year three
movies per year
versus four movies and five TV shows
there we go there we go it's a lot
um and you still only have one Kevin
feige to oversee that I see you start to
see those problems where you know the
exciting incident for Quantum Mania is
Janet is like didn't tell anyone not to
go in the quantum realm even though she
was doodling around with the quantum
room
in a very important plot point the most
credit scene that led into end game and
all of a sudden she's like for years
wasn't paying attention while they're
building
super advanced technology in the
basement and she didn't say anything
like what that doesn't make any sense
Kevin feige can't oversee as well yeah
if you can't find you have more time it
would have been like wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait I don't even remember
what happened in the last time
does this make any sense how's that g
fuel has it been helping it does I feel
very energized in sharp-minded
did you hear that yeah use that in a
promotion G fuel you can clip me up
Elijah Jihad
do you think the Fantastic Four is stuck
in the negative Zone they're the ones
sending a signal from the shangshi
credit set credit scene that would make
the most sense
I thought they would be in the quantum
realm but if they're not there they must
be stuck in the negative Zone I really
don't know what they're going to be
doing with the Fantastic Four but but
they seem confident about it sort of I'm
actually more excited about the director
they have like because I love Wanda
Vision so I'm actually really excited to
see what he can do for a big screen
adaptation yeah
yeah we just rewatched uh one division
um do you like it
yeah it kind of reminded me of all the
because I remember like it ending in the
disappointment of oh all my theories oh
they why did they tease some of these
things and didn't like why would you
bring in Evan Peters for it
that's just a way to that's not the
audience being like oh I've got a theory
you picked someone that obviously is
gonna make us think you're tying this to
the boxes it was kind of addictive
um
it's a dick move yeah any so it leads to
disappointment yeah definitely but
um you're re-watching it's remote like
how creative interesting it was and
that's what like my kids love watching
that one and it's like they're like oh
there's TV shows these are based off
like that's the premise of the show kids
um so it's been fun uh Bronson plays we
uh I'll ask John I had him you know
email it to you but thank you for the
Super Chat I had him email it to you I'm
uh I seriously we shot it I remember I
remember the whole thing the whole
experience but I'll send all right so
here's we're gonna do super quick as you
wrap this up we're gonna do a speed
round yeah of super speed we're talking
like 10 10 second answers no longer get
them in and then we're gonna then we're
gonna end this stream what time is it
Jen
set the timer for three minutes
set a timer guys start getting your
questions in hurry hurry speed round in
the live chat
the normal chat why is there no
questions coming in I saw you guys
asking questions okay Vlad Marvel's
taking their time uh not really disagree
slow mode is on but by only 15 seconds
to the finger pose again all right where
we at on time Jen
mcu's definitely kind of it feels like
they're rushing a little bit to King
Dynasty
it's several years away I mean they
introduced him and Loki two years ago
you're out of time Sean there's finally
you guys see they're making three Dexter
spin-offs Cody Leach is not excited
about that
Trinity Origins
literally that's one of them what Dexter
Origins what's it already did in the
show waste of time
did not see any Superman Lois teaser all
right at Deadpool is going to be good I
think that'll be I feel like that I have
I have faith Sean love is good and I
feel like they're gonna let them do
that's the one where I'm like they're
gonna let them do their own thing right
and so much that Ryan Reynolds he knows
what people want time Jen
doesn't matter all right who are your
picks for MCU Reed Richards I want Finn
wolfhard
that's a great pick right there I agree
with that I don't have enough time to
think about it sorry
okay all right uh Sean have you seen the
spectacular Spider-Man or other Marvel
animated shows uh the stuff from the 90s
spectacular that's great X-Men and then
Spider-Man animated series from the 90s
are the ones I've watched love the merch
guys my merch uh real rejects merch uh
how's your day been
I'm on this show it's great
would you think of Ryan Stars thoughts
in the encourage for Ant-Man in the
ending Truman Show yeah it was good it
was great her new Rockstar is awesome a
little tube of fear and Secret Wars
I feel like you got to build up to do it
I feel like uh if they just randomly
have him show up I don't think it'll be
very exciting although yes it would make
sense for Doom to be in secret Wars
simultaneously my buddy Andy at the
Comic-Con we were at a month ago
proposed that he's the actual villain
that'll be the in secret Wars he had a
whole Theory tying it into Comic runs
and everything it makes it makes a lot
of sense but at the same time I feel
like you gotta tease that he's going to
be in at first so I mean he got
Fantastic Four beforehand yeah
TV show yes I think they can pull it off
but it's Amazon who knows Sean which one
God of War I haven't played the game oh
sounds amazing do you think X-Men will
show up before after Sega Wars after
Secret Wars right correct well X-Men 97
move up next question uh are you excited
for the rest of phase five of the MC or
chapter one of guns uh I'm more excited
for guns DCU the honest answer guns DC
okay you guys set up for the Avatar The
Last I remember live action kind of
pretty worried about it I love the show
haven't I've seen about seven episodes
of the show I have no investment the
movie from Shyamalan was great though
right everybody right yeah except for
Fantasy three yes gonna be react to him
next week did not see the trailer for
Lucy Hank trailer that sounds cool uh I
don't think we'll drop the ball in that
last of us
Sean and get the last one in there the
last one what am I doing I have just
something something just give one last
question you better call it salt or
Breaking Bad they are incredibly
compliment each other is what I think
hell yeah we're ending there guys I
appreciate everyone for being here if
this is your first time seeing Sean
Chandler clearly he knows his stuff so
go follow him Sean Chandler talks about
movies and uh it's amazing stuff thank
you for everyone here on your way out if
you could leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated and hey the Pope's
Exorcist trailer was goofy as hell
did you see that dream no I have Russell
Crowe yeah
think about it I was like oh it just
looks like a joke but John campy
apparently thought it was terrifying I'm
like no no no no alrighty guys show it
to my kids I am going to uh peace out
and um I wish they didn't bring jack-in
box into my house because I've been
thinking about it since they showed up I
know Mommy I don't eat meat all right